welcome to the 45th annual conference of
the Middle East Institute as people are
getting seated I'd like first of all to
inform you about some of the changes in
the program which I understand happen
every year I'll go through all of the
program so that you'll be aware prior to
the beginning of each panel what's going
to happen
unfortunately I regret to say Hanan
Ashrawi is not able to be with us today
she's back in Ramallah radwan agua Yosh
will replace her on that panel to
present the Palestinian perspective Ken
here who's in control
I'll repeat Hanan Ashrawi is unable to
be with us today and her place will be
taken by rod whanau boy Yosh a
journalist from the West Bank who will
present the Palestinian perspective on
the first panel dan kertzer is also
unable to participate in this panel and
instead we'll have dr. william quant who
will act as moderator and who will
briefly address the American role on
that issue panel 2 will proceed without
any change in panel 3 we have one change
we were unable to arrange for a
participant to come from Tehran and
instead we've called on Shireen hunter
to address the topic of Iran and the
Gulf I'm sure you won't be disappointed
panel for participation remains
unchanged on panel 5 tomorrow morning
the second panel tomorrow Hisham Melhem
will be the moderator both Edward Saeed
our original panelist and sorry new SEBI
who's listed in the program in the
printed program were prevented from
participating by unforeseen medical
problems therefore will have as listed
abdelbaki her masih who will focus on
the Maghreb and we will have Asad Abu
Khalil who will look at the near eastern
area and Muhammad Hockey will give an
overview with special attention to Egypt
finally the student session Saturday
afternoon will not be chaired by Bill
quant who has a travel commitment out of
town but rather by Helen a common same
time same place there's no change in the
banquet speaker as listed
we will be welcoming former senator
George McGovern who will address
American policy and the settlements
issue some tickets for the banquet are
still available at the registration desk
for those wishing to join us for this
event there is a special discount for
the banquet for faculty and students
thank you for noting these changes for
every session including the keynote
address which will begin in a minute
there will be a question and answer
period there are three by five cards
around the room on the chairs please
write out your questions they'll be
collected by staff of the Middle East
Institute during the presentations and
given to the moderator who will then
pick and choose amongst them and present
them to the speakers as I said that
applies to the first talk also our
keynote speaker to open the conference
this morning is Christopher Hitchens
who writes for the nation Harper's and
New York Newsday he's currently
conducting a study of Kurdistan for the
National Geographic he's the author of
many books including hostages to history
Cyprus from the Ottomans to Kissinger
and co-authored with Edward Sayid book
titled blaming the victims he's also the
author of a study of the anglo-american
special relationship entitled blood
class and nostalgia another of his books
deals with the so called elgin marbles
the statuary removed from the Parthenon
on the Acropolis early in the last
century
mr. Hitchens was X which was educated at
mr. Hitchens was educated at Oxford
University's Bailey oak College his
topic today is the Middle East and
American democracy
mr. Chan's ambassador Keely ladies and
gentlemen I chose this topic with care
after having in the course of an
argument about the lack of partisan
politics in Washington not long ago been
told that if I wanted a multi-party
system I should go back to Russia and I
felt I felt them as I feel now that
there is arguably a false distinction in
what we describe as the domestic and the
international agenda and I'm going to
try and and repair that breach in my
remarks this morning possibly my most
conservative colleague in the
journalistic profession is the BBC
Middle East correspondent John Simpson
some of you I know have met him and
followed his work he was the man who put
in the most time in Baghdad during the
Gulf War resisting the general flight
from that city of the International
Press and he's just published a book in
England called from the house of war
which you won't have seen yet so I'm in
a position to share with you as people
sometimes like to say to extracts that
particularly caught my eye the first
describes an episode in May 1987 and
I'll I'll read briefly an extract from
John Simpsons book by the beginning of
1987 if not before American satellite
and radar intelligence was being handed
to Iraq in considerable quantities in
the United States had become an active
if secret partner interrupts battle
against Iran American intelligence
officers plotted the movements were run
in troops and planes and passed
information on to Iraq according to one
officer who served with them to American
warships the USS stark and her sister
ship Koontz
had the task of radioing the coordinates
of targets which American intelligence
officers themselves recommended to the
Iraqis and guiding them on
attack on the 17th of May 1987 to exer
set missiles from an Iraqi Air Force
mirages home did accidentally on the
radio beam from the stark which was
directing the pilot to his target
following the beam down they struck the
stock amidships killing 37 American crew
men and injuring dozens of others the
incident was not allowed to interfere
with the strategic decision to help Iraq
in its war with Iran Saddam Hussein
wrote President Reagan a fulsome letter
of apology and cooperated in full with
an American Board of Inquiry the Reagan
administration did not even ask Iraq for
compensation since it understood
perfectly well that the incident had
been an unfortunate technical accident
here's John Simpson reporting on the
situation in the Middle East and
American policy in 1987 now hears him
reporting on it in 1991 a large shelter
has been struck in Baghdad it has turned
out not to be a hardened command and
control center but to be packed with
frightened civilians and here's the
eyewitness description of what was found
within inside the building it was still
hot this is the following day inside the
building it was still hot in the rescue
workers were still finding bodies some
of the bodies were complete others had
been fused together by the heat in the
blast and lay crooked and absurd on the
stretchers as the rescuers ran out with
them eager to finish the terrible job
and get away sometimes there would be
nothing but a great mass of flesh
downstairs the surface of the water was
one inch thick in melted human fat now
between 1987 and 1991
in other words American policy shifted
from helping Saddam Hussein to guiding
Exocet missiles onto Iranian targets to
turning his civilian population into
soap meanwhile it was discovered in 1986
1987 that another faction of American
foreign and military policy was also
covertly engaged on the opposite side of
that war in
ensuring that the Iranians had the
weaponry with which to deflect and the
Iraqi attack and attempting to pay for
those weapons with other human warm
bodies in the shape of American hostages
now these three policies could be
described as contradictory but that
wouldn't be my point about them my point
about them was that however these
changes in policy all these variations
in policies were connected it was not
considered right that any of us in this
room should know of them that these
policies were decided in secret that
they were conducted with secret
diplomacy using the the methods of
covert arms trading secret hostage
dealing and other more traditional as
well as less orthodox methods and we
therefore can deny if we will
responsibility for the exits for the
soap for the hostages for the arms
trading for the whole thing because it
wasn't considered proper or necessary
that we be informed or consulted about
it but that is the connection between
consideration of the policy and
consideration of the idea of a
democratic republic that imagines itself
to be sovereign over such policies the
fact that the United States could
secretly be on both sides of a war with
two sharply distinct countries and
cultures which its citizens our citizens
were the same time legibly were all but
at war with the United States is bizarre
and it turned out that everybody knew
more about it than Congress did the
Saudi Arabians turned out to be the
finances of the Nicaragua policy the
Israelis turn out to be the armourers
and the directors of the Iranian policy
these are the policies of the United
States men who had blown up the United
States Embassy in Kuwait and were being
held in prison there were told on tape
to hang on until Oliver North could get
round to brokering their release and not
even the Secretary of State knew of
these channels of policy indeed so
widespread was the ignorance of policy
that the man responsible for it the
president the United States was almost
able to sound convincing when claiming
to know nothing of
himself and when all this double-dealing
broke down we had to render hundreds of
Iraqis into fat melted fat and then have
a celebration of our United National
sense of purpose now I think that this
leaves me plenty of scope for a critique
of the relationship between American
democracy and American foreign policy
and I'll mention some of the more
salient headings before I take your
questions and I will try and remain
conscious of the time now any country of
course and people can make a mistake
about Saddam Hussein the United States
has made I think three major mistakes
about him in the recent past and the
Palestinians for example made one only
last year but there is a difference the
Palestinians are not allowed to recover
from the mistake in the same way that we
can they are told they have no margin
for ever for error excuse me on the
contrary I doubt there's anyone in this
room who hasn't heard it said and
perhaps hasn't disputed it where it is
said that the Palestinians lack of
circumspection about Saddam Hussein in
the Gulf War now disqualifies them from
being considered for self-determination
that in some sense they are not allowed
to make the mistakes that United States
has made that miscalculations on their
part may lead to a complete denial of
their right to statehood and
self-government the Palestinian people
alas for us cannot be so readily
dismissed
they are responsibilities of the United
States they live it mustn't be forgotten
to all intents and purposes under a Pax
Americana the conditions of their lives
the conditions of the occupation the
conditions of their economy the
conditions of their exile internal and
external our conditions that are set by
departments in this city
the Treasury Department the Defense
Department the State Department and also
by the legislative branch which votes
the relevant titles deeds grants and
endowments that allow this Pax Americana
to continue in other words it's not a
responsibility that can be lightly
shrugged off especially since the
Palestinian people some time ago served
notice that taking one consideration
with another they would rather die or at
least risk death than continue to endure
the conditions that we calmly have
determined for them this in other words
is a is a rejection at all points
democratically decided by a whole people
educated intelligent cultured at the
center of the Middle East of a policy
which therefore seems to me we might
have to we consider I think a start
could be made in reconsideration if we
cleaned up a little the terms of speech
which we employ when we discuss it I'll
say briefly what I mean
no service it seems to me is tons of
democracy by referring to and the
Israelis and the Palestinians anymore
than it used to be when the vulgar
ization was the Israelis and the Arabs
the success of the Intifada at least
taught newscasters and some politicians
to refer to the Palestinians as a people
in their own right role in Israel versus
the Arabs but there still needs to be a
little more distinction made I think if
we're to think democratically and to
deal democratically with others for an
example Senator Paul Wellstone of
Minnesota this year attended a
conference sponsored by Chicken magazine
for the Israeli peace movement in the
American peace movement in Jerusalem in
doing so he became the first American
senator ever to go to Israel in order to
meet with the peace movement alone it is
considered enough for most senators to
go to Israel to meet only the government
and to consider that they have met the
Israelis we do no service to those in
Israel who may even potentially be a
majority who are in favor of a
consideration of land for peace who
worried about the militarization of
their society and the corruptions of the
occupation not to treat with them as if
they were democracy to and not to adjust
our own democratic sites to that
consider a
and it seems to me a scandal that the
world's greatest deliberative body has
so far fielded only one senator once on
the other side of this point very simple
point that I'm making in other words it
isn't enough just to say of Israel that
we support it because it's the only
democracy in the Middle East if it is
not it's democratic aspect and it's
democratic method and it's democratic
tradition that we are in fact supporting
if it turns out that indeed we are
supporting the militarizing and the
fanatical and the Orthodox and the
uniform aspects that in turn threaten
that Democratic state in other words
here again I think there's enormous room
for self-criticism now it's been argued
by some people that the original sin of
American policy in in the region was its
attempt to enter the region as if you
like the successor to British
imperialism in other words to enter the
region not as an honest broker or
disinterested superpower but as the
successor to a discredited colonialism
and it's been argued that the the the
hinge moment was the overthrow of the
Masonic government in Iran in 1953 with
the collusion of the Central
Intelligence Agency and the Anglo
American oil corporation um I think that
that would be too pessimistic and too
uniform a reproach to make though it
must be said that that period also
inaugurated a time where too much policy
was franchised to covert operators to
arms dealers to other people who in our
own culture do not necessarily play
anymore Democratic a role and they do
overseas however we are this month
commemorating the anniversary of a
rather more serious attempt at American
even-handedness in the region in that
month in 1956 as Keith Kyle's excellent
new book on the Suez Crisis points out
the British and French and Israeli
attack on Egypt was coordinated in such
a way as to make a bet that in America
in the throes of an
election would not dare rain in the
Israelis and it's a pleasure to read
Keith Kyle and his account of how this
cynical maneuver turned out to
underestimate American democracy
it's rather salutary in fact to read
though of the rage of President
Eisenhower and of his Secretary of State
John Foster Dulles at the very idea that
such a calculation could be made that
American democracy attachment to the
rule of law and even had Ennis was so
likely to be set aside and the
insistence on the resolutions of United
Nations only immediate withdrawal of
illegally from illegally occupied
territory and the very Swift listing of
what consequences would follow if this
program was not carried out now I think
we could contrast that with today where
President Bush faced with the illegal
policy of settlement and occupation has
indeed made an issue of matter of timing
and of the matter of finance but has not
so far availed himself either of an
appeal to the American electorate to
consider return responsibilities in this
or of the large and growing chief of
United Nations resolutions which if
implemented would put axiomatically an
end to the settlement problem in and of
themselves it is remarkable given that
the United States was prepared to go to
war ever only a few months ago for
United Nations resolution that this
recourse to resolutions of the UN hasn't
been made by the President or Secretary
of State in the present crisis now the
other night on ABC Nightline to be
exactly the night before last tapes were
played in which Israeli officials warned
American officials that they could if
they chose release documents and
evidence that would show the major press
conference made in this city on a
foreign policy matter by the US Attorney
General was a tissue of lies I don't how
many of you saw it but there was a mere
omnia on tape saying
oliver north how have you let the
Attorney General do this how don't you
know that we can make your Attorney
General look a fool anytime we like
don't you know we have the goods on him
excuse me I get excited when I recall it
sir don't you know in other words that
you are a hostage to our policy there
are some who say that it's conceivable
that this is a revenge by the Israelis
for a policy determined by the State
Department that they currently find
embarrassing if that was true or that it
could even be said and that this could
be materialized in other words is a
tremendous warning to us of the blowback
consequences of undemocratic foreign
policy it shouldn't be the case that
security policeman and national security
figures in other countries can as it
were hold American democracy hostage to
policies that should have been
determined by Congress and that have not
been and here if you like if I can use
in our murdered phrase is the dialectic
between one kind of democracy and
another between as it were ours and
theirs I think we have an hour I still
want to leave time for your questions we
have three test cases on this that
confront us now the first is the
Palestinians where I think I've sketched
the reasons why we have no right to
discern or abandon them well why they
have to be considered an American
responsibility before us is a very
simple question should they be allowed
to submit their own delegation which
have a delegation of their own choice
and selection added out of peace
conference sponsored by the United
States excuse me I remember hearing how
the ebon many years ago saying that he
could foresee a day when the Israelis
could pick their own delegation to a
peace conference and he could also
foresee a day when they might have to
forswear picking the Palestinian one now
he was joking
but we can't be joking as a matter of
fact it still remains to be said by
other the President or the Secretary of
State that the Palestinians have simply
that elementary right I think we can do
no less than demand for them what we
would ask for ourselves the right to
pick our own delegates the second
example of people I think we have no
right to abandon other people of
Kurdistan these are people to whom
promises have been made of
self-determination of the right to live
in peace and also of the right to take
part in discussions about the
democratization of their of the wider
societies in which they live the
societies of Iran Syria obviously and
very notably Iraq but also Turkey now I
think I'm not alone in having the
impression that that promise which has
been made by more than one
administration it's considered very
slightly embarrassing at the moment
there doesn't seem to be all that much
enthusiasm in Washington just now for
the demands of Kurdish democracy and
self-determination I think again we have
the responsibility of not letting that
subject be stricken from the agenda and
finally we have the case of the other
electoral parliamentary western-style
democracy in the Middle East namely of
the Republic of Cyprus it's been much
too long now it's been nearly 17 years
since that island was forcibly
partitioned in open defiance of the
expressed will of the majority of its
inhabitants subjected to foreign
occupation subjected to the bringing of
colonists and settlers in order to alter
the demography of the island and in
other ways maimed and amputated both as
a republic and as a democracy setting an
extremely bad precedent for local
self-aggrandizement in the region and
again this is a responsibility that
Americans cannot duck both people a
major participant outside powers in this
quarrel Greece and Turkey are in the
first place in nature allies and in the
second place are recipients of enormous
quantities of American military and
economic aid it is not therefore full
you know
it states to wash its hands of the
consequences of the policies followed by
people who can properly be described as
its proxies in all these in all these
cases I stress there is the availability
of principles already adumbrated already
reiterated and already implicit in our
end democracy we are being asked in
other words to do no more than to live
up to what we have already demanded for
ourselves and undertaken through United
Nations resolutions on Palestine on
Kurdistan and on Cyprus for others I I
began with the suggestion that there was
an original sin in 1953 in Iran and I'll
wind down by alluding to this suggestion
that there was another sin in 1980 that
in 1980 an American election was held
hostage to an overseas policy that the
exploitation of American hostages
allowed a political campaign partisan
campaign in this country in concert with
the agents of at least two other foreign
powers thereon in Israel to intervene
actually to negate to distort the
results of an American presidential
election this must still be regarded
Congress is sitting on it now I say
sitting on it in the sense of convening
on it I hope an inquiry and which the
members of the panels were nominated
this week and what looks to be a very
devastating book is about to fall from
the press written by a man known to some
of you captain Gary sick then of the
National Security Council if it were to
turn out to be true that the revenge for
intervention in Iranian internal affairs
in 1953 was an Iranian intervention in
American internal affairs in 1980 I
could I think claim to have encapsulated
the point I wanted to make Benjamin
Franklin when asked him by lady as he
left the famous meeting in Philadelphia
what have you given us we said well
madam
a republic if you can if you can keep it
those of us who want to Revere and and
maintain Republican and Democratic
virtues have to be on our guard against
threats to them both from domestic and
foreign enemies I think we would do well
to make common cause with those who in
their own countries call for democracy
and become in that way the more staunch
guarantor of our own thank you
do we have any more questions from the
monitors the the first question thank
you is why did the US and its allies
leave Saddam Hussein in power I think
the answer to that is they thought they
might need him again I don't mean to
sound cynical about it but it wouldn't
be the first time that the calculation
had been made a in principle you're
familiar with the old remark made
actually by Roosevelt about Samara well
he may be a bastard but he may be our
bastard in other words that there's
there's a that that consideration has
been known to influence policy before in
general I think in particular it was
very noticeable that and is noticeable
in the written record right up until the
last few closing staves of April glass
B's long transcripts that Saddam Hussein
was considered as at least a candidate
in the role of an American favorite in
the in the rather chaotic situation that
still obtains for American interests in
the aftermath of the collapse of the
Shah of Iran there was also to be even
more specific very strong Saudi pressure
against any breakup or sometimes called
Lebanese ation of Iraq in particular any
breakup that might open the possibility
of a Saudi excuse me of a Shia
Protectorate or Iranian Protectorate so
near the Saudi border and I think when
the Saudis thought about it they thought
they wanted a Sunni Muslim military
dictatorship in Baghdad though they
would rather have had one that didn't
include Saddam they'd rather have had
Saddam's dictatorship then not have one
at all and I think that was the kind of
pragmatism for which the ground in
Washington had been very well-mannered
second question why did the American and
European press fail to provide a
plausible critique of US policies and
military actions during the Gulf War
cowardice and and conformism I went on
the press plane to Desert Shield not a
desert storm for one longest trip with
the president and realized then and
there that all the technical ingredients
and most of the moral ingredients for
the creation of a megaphone a press or
had already been put in place before the
first shot was fired nothing that
happened afterwards did anything to
disappoint me in that respect I was I
was surprised however by the extent to
which so many of my colleagues were
prepared
I said well should volunteer to do
things before the administration asked
them to do so I think the mass
evacuation of the press from Baghdad on
the eve of of the bombing remains the is
the single greatest disgrace and the
greatest breach of faith with readers
and viewers that the the press has yet
been guilty of do you think we're
hostage to Israel enforcing Soviet Jews
to go to Israel should we reopen and
double our quotas to solve this problem
not sure whose hostage to who in that
case I mean there is there's a visit
there's a multiple collusion in involved
here first it's true that with the with
pressure from Israel's friends in this
country it's become harder for a Soviet
Jew wishing to choose his country or her
country of residence to choose the
United States it's rather it's a little
known fact that the United States
imposes a numerus clausus of a quota on
say the Jewish immigration second it's
been negotiated between the Israeli
government and the Soviet government
though not very many people are aware of
it that any Soviet Jew leaving the
Soviet Union automatically surrenders
his or her citizenship something that an
American or German or French or English
Jew doesn't have to do if they want to
go and try
making realia in other words that's a
further narrowing of the options and
third that third-party countries transit
countries for this traffic in people who
were frightened enough to want to leave
the Soviet Union and who are uncertain
but who wished but who's the governor of
Israel wants to direct to live in Israel
transit countries are a frowned upon by
the Israelis if they don't sign an
agreement saying that they will pass
arriving surveyor Jews on only to an
Israeli destination and in fact they
have been quarrels between the Israeli
government and the government of both
Finland and Czechoslovakia who say no
anyone who comes to our Airport is
entitled to pick their own word
destination that doesn't sit well with
the Israeli Ministry of absorption it is
I think really deplorable that a state
policy in which our own administration
is complicit should exploit one
oppressed and endangered people the
survey of Jews in order further to
increase that the difficulties and the
jet privations of another oppressed and
Exploited people the Palestinian areas
of the occupied territories I think
that's a redoubled cause for shame the
the Kurds share with their cousins in
Iran an iranian race culture tradition
and history doesn't this give Iran the
motherland if you will a say in
kurdistan's future in your remarks you
seem to delegate this responsibility to
the West instead rather than to Iran
why so well I think the same could be
said by bipartisan of the idea that Iraq
or Chucky was a Kurdish motherland
because obviously the there are overlaps
between Kurdish culture and Turkish
culture and Iraqi Arab Mesopotamian
culture too so that could be said of any
of the countries where Kurdish
populations live I laid a burden on the
Western powers because undertakings have
been made to the Kurds in the past
sometimes quite solemn ones sometimes
all the cynical ones but all tending to
the view
that there should be a Western guarantee
of the right of Kurdish
self-determination whether that
self-determination takes the form of
regional autonomy negotiated with each
successive government or a wider
dispensation of self-government however
any any litter occurred in a literate
let's say in any of those languages or
cultures is entitled to say to the West
that he or she has been promised
something freely this was not a promise
extorted by the Kurds from us and and
therefore that it's a debt of honor an
obligation the the Greek majority in
Cyprus has treated the Turkish minority
as the Israelis have been treating the
Palestinians this has been substantiated
by concrete evidence
moreover the 1960 treaty between Britain
Greece and Turkey holds the parties
responsible to assure the human rights
of all parties please comment
well I can't accept the premise of the
question the Cyprus is not occupied by a
Greek army it's okay bye-bye check show
me the northern third of the island has
been completely cleared of its original
inhabitants a mass expulsion a transfer
as some Israeli politicians would call
it something that's only threatened by
the Israelis on the West Bank has
actually been quite ruthlessly carried
out in Cyprus so that a population that
was settled there in stability for many
thousands of years and can show a
continuous record of occupation of the
benign sense and civilization has simply
been decanted and deported in the
cultural traces of its presence forcibly
erased if there is therefore any analogy
at all with the treatment of the
Palestinians it would tend in the
opposite direction to the one indicated
by the questioner
why did the American media specifically
the print media support the
administration in discrediting the peace
movement I'm not sure I can really
accept the premise of that of that
question either it seemed to me that at
least before the war began if we're
talking about the same war that the such
a peace movement as there was got
reasonable play on the air my problem
actually was much with the peace
movement than with the press the peace
movement in this country in my opinion
acted in a very narrow isolationist an
almost chauvinistic way it said that a
war was more or less alright with it as
long as that it could be guaranteed in
advance that an American casualties
would be kept low or minimal thought
that was a dishonorably narrow way of
approaching the question but it would
explain why there wasn't really any
protest when that was done because some
that guarantee could be given as long as
the war was fought only in Iraq and
fought only from the air where there was
no possibility of retaliation but
unfortunately that also meant that when
large numbers of Iraqis were turned into
soap as I just described you and many
others as we've since found out were
bulldozed and buried alive and in other
way it's done away with and people don't
even want to think about the body count
really at all was they're afraid of what
they might find out there was no protest
rather there was I think a deplorable
sense of relief that that these were the
way casualties were being registered
indeed I've heard quite intelligent
people say only what what a relief it
was that so few people were killed
during the war and what they mean is so
few Americans please comment on the fact
that so many people in the Arab world in
the third world in general including
many intelligent and well-educated
individuals are convinced that Saddam
Hussein is a CIA agent I think instinct
tells them that he would be flattered to
be asked to be a CIA agent but I don't
think there's any evidence that he has
ever been more than briefly considered
for that role I think that it said it is
certainly the case that for long period
during the Gulf War here in the United
States were in a sense fighting in the
same trench this certainly had a made a
convincing impression on the on the
Iranians and I think possibly what may
be meant by the question is that here's
a man as it were capable of large and
protein changes we may not have seen the
end of them that's all we have time for
thank you very much Christopher Hitchens